We love technology.
And with it, we believe that we can achieve great things.
Open Planet Ideas is a place where you can collaborate to identify environmental issues,...
...and then tackle them as a community...
...using Sony technology in new and clever ways.
The challenge will take you through different phases before we come to a final idea.
Inspiration is where you can tell us what you care about...
...from an environmental issue on your doorstep...
...to something on the other side of the world.
What inspires you to act sustainably,...
...or what other smart uses of technology have caught your eye.
Next, our expert panel will sort and group your inspirations into popular themes.
During concepting, we want you to share your ideas on how we can use existing Sony technology...
...in exciting, innovative ways to meet these challenges.
Don't worry if you're feeling short of ideas yourself.
You can comment, applaud, or build on other people's.
The best concepts will then move on to evaluation...
...where they'll be rated by this community of users,...
...as well as by our expert panel.
Which ideas are the most elegant, the most beneficial, or the most viable?
Let us know what you think.
We'll develop the final idea into a proof of concept, or even a working prototype.
So if you want to work alongside Sony's engineers and WWF to make your idea a reality,...
...get involved now.